say questions for Kyle mark here in the
third row kyle mark schwartz ESPN us
earlier that he talked to you before the
game and there was a sign on the board
that said let it rip tell me what that
meant to you and how you think you let
it rip to think you let it rip tonight
compared to how you play it first - I
think that was more of a message for the
team
we shot 38 threes a night and you know
we got up a lot of threes a lot of
attempts and just play play basketball
for me it was just coming up being
aggressive and you know not not not try
and get everybody else involved and more
so get myself going and you know I'd let
everybody else feed off of that
Kyle Michael Grange from Sports Net I
mean when you found out the clay wasn't
playing did it really feel like this was
an opportunity you guys had to try and
take advantage of tonight was there that
added urgency obviously you want to win
every game but yeah I mean you know when
you lose a NBA type basketball player
and clay and all-star you definitely you
know it changes their team but I mean
their team but I mean Steph had on blue
a game you know in 47 points and is
pretty pretty impressive but you know we
sitting out there and did our job and
you know I think you know we played well
we finished a game and we found a way to
win a basketball game standing all the
way in the back
Kyle Jonathan show with dear TV you had
a pretty big breakout game this third
game and the entire team of starters
scored in double digits what did you do
to approach this game differently to
really help this balanced attack kept
the pace up kept kept you know kept our
pace up and kept going and you know
trying to get the ball out quick and get
his ball out quick and getting stops and
communication and just kept playing you
know we know that they're possible they
always can make runs in this building
but you know we stayed level at it just
continue to kind of you know just keep
going and going and going and staying in
a moment janie all the way in the back
hi Kyle Janie McCauley from ap to find
an answer every time they hit a big shot
her stuff got a big shot somebody came
up with a play and also I did see the
fan shove you I'm the fan shove you on
the sideline on the court side there and
how disappointing was that but for us we
just you know we know that they're gonna
make good runs and um we watched that
third quarter
you know Game two and we just got to
continue to play with pace and and that
was the one thing about it we played
with pace half court for court and that
was a big thing for us and that's what I
found there's no place in him for that
you know he had no reason to touch me he
had no region and who reached over
treating and who reached over two seats
and then say some vulgar language to me
it's no place for people like that in
our league and you know hopefully he
never goes becomes back to NBA game go
ahead on the right side it sounds like
Kevin Durant's pretty close and klay
Thompson may also come back again for
how much over the next through that and
almost you know I guess I guess scheme
for two different teams I'm just gonna
prepare the same way you know we're um
we're Road defensive mighty team you
know we know they got those type of you
know we know they got those type of but
there was those weapons but we got to
just prepare ourselves to be focused on
ourselves and that's the one thing we've
always done and it's kind of continue to
work on ourselves and work on what we
can do you know we can't control
anything else you know what the Warriors
do we just got to go out there and do a
week and do to get better continue to
grow I see well we Tim standing in the
back left Kyle Tim Reynolds with the AP
the finals is obviously you know it was
a new frontier for a lot of you guys
before Game one and Nick what he's gone
through this year and the circumstances
and replacing Dwayne and all that
stuff's all been well covered but how
how much does he impressed you at this
time of year with he looks like a guy
who's done this a whole bunch of times
instead of never before he got a lot of
championships you know his in in England
and the G League and I mean Nick you
know he looks young but he's pretty old
but he's been doing this a long time and
his demeanor like I've said this before
he literally
the elder that's like twice this whole
season and his demeanor is just kind of
you know just you know keep going and
keep going and figure it out and you
know all right this is what we can do
this is what's happening and his mind
for the game has been special and you
know the growth throughout the year has
been pretty good for him you know he's
not the first time head coach is the
first time NBA head coach but the
experience that he's had you know and
his his many leagues and teams that he's
been a head coach before he's kind of
just kind of you know stepped up and
continue to grow with that Eric in the
center thank you Eric pingas basketball
insiders leach report kind of the past
years your team has kind of hit a brick
wall in the playoffs and obviously
you've broken through can you share how
the team has grown together to fight
through I mean even down the end the
stretch of this game this team didn't
quit how have you guys grown to talent
to meet those challenges I think we just
added a you know a couple great pieces
you know added in Kauai and Mark and
Danny with their professionalism I think
you know their championship look Danny's
in khawaja championship pedigree Nick's
you know coming in as a coach that's you
know won a few championships in G League
and we we got a Patrick McCall who's got
a couple championships we got a bunch of
guys who were you know professionals and
we got a good veteran group and we all
kind of just you know understand that
this is you know it's our job and never
get too up never get too down you know
teams are gonna you know make runs and
you're gonna not win every game you're
not gonna lose every game but you can
continue to grow you know to the point
to play you know to until June and that
was always the goal with this team was
to get to June Thank You Kyle Thank You
Leonard and green we'll be right up
for some room